- So Max, what did you bring?
- I brought my laundry.
- Your laundry?
- Yeah, uh, where's Michael?
- Where's Michael?
Michael's up here in the blue.
- What's up man?
How you doin?
Great job.
I get, I don't know if
you get the, I get lists.
Uh...
- [Kelly] Oh, from your wife?
- My wife gives me lists.
- [Kelly] Mmhm.
- Um, and I have a pretty big one today.
So I thought, and this is
so, I'm so happy to be here.
I'm very excited.
- [Kelly] Well thank you.
- But I have a lot to get done.
- In one day.
You gotta make it happen.
- So I thought I'd multitask.
- Okay.
Okay.
I like it.
Can I tell you something
really funny real quick?
Um...
My sister's watching right now
and she's gonna hate me for this but...
- Why?
- Every time folding laundry
when they tell their kids
"well we're folding laundry".
(laughing)
We're folding laundry.
So I love that you came
out here to fold laundry.
- That's so funny because
in our house uh...
We tell the kids that we're
folding laundry and uh...
And we're folding laundry.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I love it.
You just keep foldin man.
Just help her out.
- I'm excited.
- Can I help you fold?
- If I posted those...
Yeah, sure.
- Okay just lay 'em right here.
I am really good at it.
- It's all clean.
- I'm really, even if it's dirty, I'm in.
- If I had posted...
- I'm wearin it.
- If I had posted those pictures online
my wife would have been like, "yeah, and?"
(laughing)
- My, I know I was like,
I love these pictures.
It's like what like
wives have been doing for
centuries.
Its fine.
Its like
centuries.
- I always find...
- I went real big with it.
- I always find it odd
to fold my kids clothes.
- Oh really?
I love the miniature ones
'cause they're easier.
You know what I hate?
A fitted sheet.
- But it's...
It's like origami though.
A fitted sheet's
- I want a...
- very difficult.
- I want to
set a sheet on fire
when I fold a fitted sheet.
I literally just end up doing this.
I start out so proud
and then I just do this.
- No, yeah.
- It's like horrible.